we really have to come to terms and deal
with the reality that the president
Donald Trump is just not a good person
period and there are always ways to
write off horrifying behavior right when
he said grab him by the you-know-what
well what he meant is grab him by the
you-know-what because they let you
because you're famous so it's not really
unwanted sexual contact or when he made
fun of the disabled reporter that
insulting caricature that he did it only
seemed like he was mimicking the
reporters specific disability but really
he wasn't it was just some coincident
right you can defend it but the latest
tweet you can defend it I don't the
latest tweets and comments about the
horrifying situation that fellow
American citizens in Puerto Rico are
suffering through right now is one where
there can be no other explanation other
than Trump is not a good person
Puerto Rico has been ravaged by the
recent hurricanes everything from power
to food to water is in short supply to
begin with Donald Trump's response was
slow weak almost not there eventually
after media coverage grew around Puerto
Rico and Trump definitively figured out
or someone told him that Puerto Ricans
are American citizens he started taking
some sort of action and saying some
things that made him sound like a sort
of moderately empathetic person when
you're President of the United States
and fellow citizens are suffering this
way but this imploded over the weekend
the mayor of San Juan was pleading for
help pleading for help and Donald Trump
was golfing endless nonprofits and
activists were working feverishly to try
to not only raise money for Puerto Rico
but to figure out how to get it where it
needs to be and start making change in
Puerto Rico and Trump was tweeting that
Puerto Ricans just want everything
handed to them the mayor of sung Kwan
herself Carmen Yulin Cruz speaking here
we are dying here tonight to not fathom
the thought
that the greatest nation in the world
cannot figure out the logistics for a
small island of a hundred miles by
thirty five months so I am asking the
President of the United States to make
sure somebody is in charge that is up to
the task of saving lives begging and
pleading and what does Trump do he takes
to Twitter to attack the mayor starting
with the mayor of San Juan who was very
complimentary only a few days ago has
now been told by the Democrats that you
must be nasty to Trump such poor
leadership ability by the mayor of San
Juan and others in Puerto Rico who were
not able to get their workers to help
they want everything to be done for them
when it should be a community effort
10,000 federal workers now on island
doing a fantastic job and then another
sort of indirect slight at the people of
Puerto Rico who I guess according to
Trump are not quote working hard when
Trump went back on Twitter and praised
the people in the US Virgin Islands
saying quote I will be going to Puerto
Rico on Tuesday with Melania will
hopefully be able to stop at the US
Virgin Islands people working hard and
what makes these tweets even worse that
Trump was once again playing golf all
weekend at his own Golf Resort in New
Jersey hanging out and funneling more
taxpayer money into his family
businesses this is a shameful disgrace
it's a shameful time for the United
States and there has to be some
component here about the stereotype of
the lazy Hispanic right I mean can any
one of us imagine Donald Trump faced
with desperation for help and aid from
for example the mayor of Colorado
Springs a white middle-aged man reacting
on Twitter that Coloradans just want
everything to be handed to them can
anyone really imagine that and of course
it's not just Puerto Ricans it's a brown
skinned Hispanic woman who's the one
saying they need help and we really need
the President to put someone in charge
of this beyond bizarre beyond
embarrassing the mayor of San Juan was
not being nasty to trump she's
esprit and making a plea for help
because people are dying and she's
making plea after plea and this really
goes to Trump's insecurities right how
insecure is Trump he must be realizing
that he is seen as incompetent and he
just can't seem to do anything right
because a plea for help from a mayor
about fellow American citizens that she
represents Trump sees the plea for help
I guess as trying to make him look bad
and he lashes out and a leaked White
House memo has exposed how the White
House has been trying to spin this White
House Homeland Security Advisor Tom
Bossert sent other staffers a list of
talking points one of those talking
points that leaked is quote the storm
caused these problems not our response
to it yeah anyway back to Trump it is
pathological narcissism but it's also
just a bad person right and recall
Donald Trump's reaction after 9/11
happened he was interviewed on wwo our
just hours after the World Trade Center
went down on 9/11 he was asked about the
fallen twin towers Trump's first comment
was that as a result of the destruction
of the Twin Towers his building on Wall
Street was now the tallest building in
the neighborhood in lower Manhattan oh
yeah and of course it's just horrible
and unbelievable what's going on that's
not a good person and and as a side note
just as a final dot at the end of this
sentence the term in terms of the
logistics of what's going on does anyone
think that if we were invading Puerto
Rico militarily we wouldn't have all the
electricity that we need to turn back on
and supplies flowing but by now but
somehow we seem unable to actually
provide the help that we need